le brillant la république accorde sa
grâce à un homme condamné à 20 ans de
réclusion pour le viol suivi de meurtre
d'une infirmière l'homme avait avoué
puis s'était aussitôt rétracté depuis
les clame son innocence roumanie des
étudiants manifestent en ce moment même
à bucarest ils craignent que la
révolution ne leur soit confisquée par
un gouvernement qu'ils jugent trop
proche de moscou les friches
industrielles un problème européen
comment réhabiliter les paysages
défigurés par l'industrie exemple une
centrale thermique dans les landes
ranquette dans cette édition
voilà monsieur bonjour le premier titre
de l'actualité de ce dimanche matin
c'est l'histoire d'un homme de 43 ans
yves ponthieu qui vient d'être libéré au
terme de neuf années de détention à la
prison de loos les lille dans le nord
après que monsieur mitterrand lui est
accordé la grâce présidentielle affaire
remonte à 1981 une infirmière violet est
ensuite assassinée bon dieu avouera le
meurtre pour aussitôt se rétracter les
preuves matérielles manqueront
cruellement mais ponthieu sera tout de
même condamné à 20 ans de prison
il en aura fait neuf finalement en
espagne je crois pas je suis comme
danseur sur un nuage
je commence à peine à réaliser que je
suis effectivement en dehors de ces
quatre murs qui est qui s'appelle la
prison ils font tuer libre depuis
vendredi soir gracié par le président de
la république
il vient de passer neuf ans en prison le
18 juillet 81 après deux coups de
téléphone anonymes les gendarmes
découvrent ici au col de la perche le
corps de monique soubeyrand infirmière à
l'hôpital de hauteville lompnès elle a
été violée puis assassinée au près du
corps les gendarmes retrouvent de livres
érotiques
le libraire de longuenesse affirmé avoir
vendu un collègue de la jeune infirmière
économe à l'hôpital yves ponthieu au
cours de sa garde à vue il ponctue à
vous puis se rétracte aussitôt condamné
à 20 ans de réclusion criminelle
il ne cesse de clamer son innocence un
comité de soutien se forment et refait
l'enquète
tout d'abord auprès du fournisseur du
libraire de lantenay cela dral diffusion
rhône-alpes du libre la vallée de
touléco les deux livres qui lui avait
été dédié les livres en question oui
figurez pas alors question comment
est-ce que ce libraire peut prétendre
que votre coin sûrement mais comment
peut-il prétendre avoir vendu des livres
qui lui avait pas été distribués
voyez vous alors il ya une série de
recherches comme ça est de deux
vérifications qui ont été faites sur la
culpabilité du pont vieux aujourd'hui
gracié if ponthieu veut maintenant être
réhabilitée il demande la révision de
son procès le combat continue dit il je
suis innocent les derniers événements à
l'est ont quelque peu fait passer à
l'arrière-plan le problème qui agitaient
souvenez-vous la france au mois
d'octobre novembre l'immigration et le
problème de l'intégration de ces
immigrés aujourd'hui à paris le parti
socialiste a réuni plusieurs centaines
de ses élus originaires d'afrique du
nord beurre pieds-noirs et de vente sont
venus planches et neuf ministres dont le
premier d'entre eux monsieur michel
rocard monsieur rocard qui a souligné
que le problème de l'intégration est
trop souvent en france at-on souvent en
france pardon comme seule conséquence de
diviser gravement les français monsieur
rocard quand je dis fracture je
l'entends de bien des façons d'abord de
la façon la plus banale et quotidienne
qui soit celle d'une société
malheureusement à plusieurs vitesses ou
l'origine étrangère et singulièrement
africaine et plus encore maghrébine est
porteuse d'exclusion et cela nous ne
pouvons pas la tête
nous ne devons pas
fracture ensuite sur le plan politique
parce que de tous temps l'exclu et
méprisés et que l'étranger l'aublette
est l'objet de la méfiance
l'exclu étrangers du coup devient bien
vite le bouc émissaire cumul de deux
facteurs d'exclusion et dès lors que les
temps sont difficiles
tout cela s'aggrave dans les méfiances
comme dans les souffrances or nos temps
sont difficiles sur le plan du vécu
comparer des uns aux autres et ils ne
manquent pas d'ailleurs
hélas d'histrion éructant ou de bateleur
d'arrière salle
sinon les strates pour prêcher la
mauvaise parole vous le savez tous fort
bien cela ne pose jamais de bonnes
questions
ne laissons même pas croire que seul les
réponses seraient mauvaises ils ne font
que semer la m et cela non plus nous ne
devons pas le supporter voilée en
conclusion le premier ministre a répété
que la france n'était plus un pays
d'immigration nous ne pouvons accueillir
ajouté le premier ministre
toutes les misères du monde à l'étranger
maintenant à bucarest les étudiants
roumains manifeste fille ciellement ce
moment même pour voir repousser la date
de leur examen pour cause de révolution
qui n'était pas inscrite au programme du
mois de décembre mais aussi en fait pour
protester contre le nouveau gouvernement
qu'il juge un peu trop près de moscou et
qu'ils accusent de lui confisquer de
leur confisquer leur révolution reporter
martine laroche-joubert gilbert ruse
ce matin plus de dix mille étudiants
pour donc réunis ici à l'aise du
polytechnique l'autorisation de
manifester dans le centre ville leur a
été refusé le prétexte cette réunion le
nouveau record de l'or d'examen en
réalité c'est plutôt un réquisitoire
adapté de représentation étudiante et
surtout la pression sur leurs fronts
puisque la révolution les étudiants de
timisoara aux mêmes menaces et de
recommencer une autre
si le gouvernement ne les écoute pas une
absence de confiance qui fait entrave et
l'action du nouveau pouvoir en roumanie
les journalistes comme martine
laroche-joubert coup une edwards à
l'instant qui ont couvert les événements
peuvent aujourd'hui chercher je dire à
raconter des petites histoires qui ont
jalonné la grande qui s'est opéré au
mois de décembre 1,6 ce médaillé
olympique romain aux tirs aux derniers
jeux de séoul a servi à sa manière la
révolution roumaine reporter martin
laroche joubert
gilles virus un homme qui pendant la
révolution des 22 et 23 décembre remplit
une mission tout à fait particulière
sort in baby champion olympique de tir à
séoul
postée ici pendant deux jours et trois
nuits à l'affût des snipers les
francs-tireurs terroristes de la
securitate et 26 ans électricien membres
du steaua
le club sportif de l'armée roumaine le
22 décembre dernier
les terroristes étaient là cachées dans
ce cimetière en face du club
leurs objectifs sont emparés pour mettre
la main sur un dépôt de munitions et
d'armements
l'affrontement fut très violent sort in
baby évidemment là des meilleurs
défenseurs du clab une formation
sportive détourné de son objectif
pendant cette révolution
avant oui j'avais pensé à cette
éventualité
parce que je m'étais demandé si je
pourrai à jour servir de ses
entraînements dans une situation où de
guerre révolutionnaire mais je n'aurais
jamais pensé à tel massacre avec tant de
violence
je pensais que ça se déroulerait comme
dans les autres pays pour sauver une
baby médaille d'or à séoul
la première victoire sans trophée à
l'est encore les partis communistes vous
le savez tente de remonter le courant le
pc polonais ainsi pourrait abandonner
son sigle communiste pendant ce week end
le p6 tchécoslovaque lui annonce que
deux cent mille de ces militants
viennent de le quitter et qu'il est
obligé de changer de siège social pour
se contenter d'un immeuble pour loyer
moins onéreux et puis monsieur
gorbatchev doit se rendre cette semaine
en lituanie dont le parti communiste
vient de faire sécession sa visite est
précédé d'une première contre
manifestation en faveur du maintien des
liens entre les différentes républiques
socialistes qui forment encore
aujourd'hui l'urss dominique darne
ce reportage a été diffusé hier dans le
grand journal du soir de la télévision
soviétique
une manifestation de soutien gorbatchev
en lituanie ce n'est pas si fréquent
avignews de 3 à 5000 personnes sont
rassemblées devant le palais des sports
sur les banderoles
un slogan principal non à la sécession
le 26 décembre les responsables du parti
communiste lituaniens ont décidé de
rompre leurs liens avec le pc d'union
soviétique
le premier pas vers un processus qui
devrait déboucher sur une quasi
indépendance de la lituanie cette
situation inquiète gorbatchev
s'il laisse faire d'autres république
pourrait vouloir suivre l'exemple
lituanie gorbatchev qui sait que les
conservateurs du pc l'attend au virage a
donc décidé de réagir vite
alors que se déroulait cette
manifestation ils recevaient au kremlin
les leaders du parti communiste
lituaniens mercredi il se rendra à
vignoux sur une visite de trois jours
avec toujours le même objectif
convaincre les communistes lituanien de
ne pas faire sécession alors que le
plénum du comité central doit bientôt se
réunir pour examiner la situation
lituanienne amérique centrale au panama
la situation se normalise après
l'arrestation et le départ du général
noriega ces dernières 24 heures les
prisonniers politiques ont été libérés
et des cache d'armes découverte claire
chazal
premier signe tangible de la fin de la
dictature noriega au panama
la libération de 91 prisonniers
politiques ils étaient détenus ici à la
prison de corbas aux dires des premiers
prisonniers interrogés les conditions de
détention étaient particulièrement dures
vous pouvez aller voir derrière n'avions
même pas de douche
nous sentons pas des hommes c'est
seulement des esclaves et puis l'armée
américaine a pu bien sûr investir les
résidences de l'ancien homme fort du
panama
ici à playa blanca beach à l'udc se
voyant ou l'ivoire s'entassent où les
figures religieuses côtoie souvent les
traces des manies du dictateur
desjardins entier transformé en saut
le nouveau pouvoir au panama va bien sûr
en prendre possession
sans oublier les nombreux comptes en
banque détenue par noriega l'étranger
qui devraient être bloqués à la demande
des américains dans le cadre de sa lutte
contre le trafic de drogue les
etats-unis ont envoyé lundi dans l'une
de leurs plus grosses unités le
porte-avions kennedy au large des côtes
de la colombie peut-être pour y
contrôler le trafic aérien et maritime
et empêcher ainsi le départ des
cargaisons de drogue vers les usa on se
croirait au cinéma vous allez le voir
sur ces images et pourtant ce n'est que
la réalité rupture de canalisation d'eau
hier matin il était 7 heures à new york
l'eau a déferlé le long de la 5e avenue
transformer en véritables rivières et
ses taux qui descendait la 5e avenue à
même inondé une station de métro on
ignore les raisons de cet accident qui
n'a fait heureusement aucune victime
mais pas mal de dégâts comme vous le
voyez sur ces images en france
recrudescence des attentats terroristes
en corse tout un matériel heureusement
depuis quelques jours maintenant à les
deux derniers en date sur l'île de
cavallo au large de bonifacio la nuit
dernière deux restaurants appartenant à
des sociétés italiennes ont été détruits
par des attentats c'est sur cette île
que doit être construit un complexe
résidentiel et portuaire de grand luxe
financés par des capitaux italiens et
l'on sait que les terroristes de l'ex
flnc sont opposés à ce type
d'investissement les élus des bouches du
rhône ont été réunis cette semaine par
la sncf qui leur a expliqué les grandes
lignes des projets des différents tracés
du tgv entre lyon la provence et la côte
d'azur projet qui ligne pardon qui
entreront en service aux alentours des
années 90 est à cette époque là et bien
on peut déjà dire que paris sera à 3
heures à peine de marseille est à quatre
heures de nice jacques deviere après
avoir battu le record du monde de
vitesse sur rail la sncf poursuit ses
programmes de réalisation des lignes à
grande vitesse
demain des tgv dans toutes les
directions vers l'europe
pour le sud-est en prolongeant la ligne
au sud de lyon vers l'espagne la
provence et la côte d'azur en 1997
paris marseille en trois heures et paris
nice quatre heures dans la région
d'aix-en-provence marseille
trois tracés possibles le premier qui
suit la vallée de la durance au nord du
massif de la sainte-victoire un deuxième
celui de la sncf
toujours au nord de la sainte victoire
et de lambesc mais au sud de venelles
enfin troisième possibilité un tracé au
sud de lambesc et d'aix-en-provence
toujours avec des raccordements vers
marseille
déjà certains élus locaux craignent que
l'environnement soit mise à mal au tracé
qui est prévu taillant en pièces le
vignoble des coteaux d'aix taillé en
pièces des propriétés agricoles très
homogène et surtout ne tient aucun
compte de l'habitat existant du
patrimoine historique avec des demeures
anciennes et autres et et des mêmes des
sites certains sites classés je crois
d'autres se félicite de l'impact
économique du tgv pour leur région pour
la sncf
rien n'est encore décidé officiellement
le tracé définitif sera fait pour fur et
à mesure de la concertation avec les
élus des communes concernées
dans plusieurs départements français se
pose le problème des friches
industrielles c'est à dire de ces lieux
désertés par l'industrie pour cause de
fin d'activité c'est même un problème
européen 2500 hectares de la communauté
européenne sont concernés un exemple en
france avec la fermeture d'une centrale
edf dans les landes à arjuzanx que son
exploitation avait bouleversé le paysage
edf s'est engagé à le remettre en place
ce paysage ainsi qu'à retrouver les
emplois perdus pour cause de fermeture
en quête de josé blanc la pierre à la
tombée de la nuit vous pouvez être sûr
de les voir elle rentre au bercail
les grues cendrées ignore qu ici
s'étendait un gisement minier avec ses
cratères devenus des étangs autour
prairies des plantations n'ont pas
poussé par hasard cette végétation a été
planifiée puis re créer de toutes pièces
à la main une nature en pleine
croissance
un vrai bonheur pour les chevreuils et
les sangliers le responsable est cet
homme arrivé en 1980 avec une mission
faire revivre un désert du poisson nous
avons des écrevisses
quand je suis arrivé ici et b il y avait
un trou d'eau avait de l'eau bien sûr
mais sans vie totalement sans vie et ça
a été de redonner un fin de compte un
petit coup de pouce par crémer donner un
petit coup de pouce à la nature pour
qu'elle reprenne normalement ses droits
voici ce qu'il a trouvé en arrivant un
spectacle lunaire sur 2700 hectares en
pleine forêt landaise entre bordeaux et
bayonne
la cause une centrale thermique ouverte
il ya trente ans un cas unique en france
lusine s'est installé sur un gisement de
lignite son propre combustible qu'elle
exploite
elle même
mais aujourd'hui victimes du nucléaire
la centrale plie bagage 600 personnes
qui s'en vont c'est beaucoup pour les
petites communes environnantes n'y a
plus personne n'y a plus de jeunes il
n'y a plus d'enfants
tout le monde s'en va ce monde pas au
café
on parle aussi de l'école qui a fermé
on n'a plus rien oublier les jeunes a
raconté avant de partir des f veut
réparer trouver de nouveaux emplois et
faire reverdir le désert qu'elle a créée
viendra ensuite le problème du
successeur à qui profitera cette terre
plein de promesses voilà ce journal est
terminée tout de suite après les
prévisions météo vous retrouverez josé
blanc lapierre quant à nous on se
retrouve ce soir à 20 heures au revoir
bon après midi à tout à l'heure
madame monsieur bonjour de la pluie sur
le sud ouest et un peu de neige sur les
pyrénées mais partout ailleurs le ciel
reste désespérément sec
voici la situation sur nos images
satellite avec une perturbation dont je
vous parlais hier elle était sur
l'atlantique
la voici aujourd'hui vous la voyez
défiler sous vos yeux actuellement c'est
la situation que nous connaissons avec
des nuages donc un peu plus important
sur le nord-est mais pas de pluie et
puis dans le sud-ouest en revanche un
peu plus d'humidité de part et d'autre
du soleil la preuve sur notre cas voici
donc le détail pour cet après-midi de la
nage mais qui est plutôt tombé cette
nuit et ce matin de la pluie sur ces
régions que vous voyez ici un petit peu
sur le massif central et sur donc le
autour des les régions qui sont autour
des piats les voilà ici c'est un petit
peu optimiste c'est à dire que le ciel
est couvert mais il y a pas de pluie
beau temps de part et d'autre comme je
vous le disais sur le nord-ouest sur le
sud est les températures pour cet après
midi elles sont un petit peu plus
fraîches sur l'est mais ont tendance à
monter quatre à dijon à strasbourg 12
sur braise 13 sur nantes et sur la
moitié sud 16 encore sur biarritz qui
vraiment pas des records de douceur
actuellement pour demain voici la
tendance les nuages qui sont et les
petites pluies qui sont sur le sud ouest
aujourd'hui vont basculer vers le sud
est mais comme vous le voyez c sera gris
mais sec du brouillard autour du
brouillard demain sur le sud-ouest le
massif central sur le nord de la région
rhône alpes mais vous pouvez voir un
retour du soleil sur toutes ces régions
qui sont au sud de la loire au nord de
la loire en revanche ciel gris plutôt
débrouillards piéger par l'anticyclone
est peut-être trois gouttes de pluies
sur les régions du nord est en fait il
n'y a pas de grands changements que vous
avez pu le constater bonne après midi
antenne 2 avec gitem vous invite à
retrouver maddie passionné volontaire
envahissant émouvante force tête et
faibles femmes c'est ma guip une cascade
de fous rires
une avalanche de gags un tourbillon de
bonne humeur
maggie vous attend pour de nouvelles
aventures dimanche 19h france
ah bon
cette fois la main de votre ancienne
voiture c'est quand même un minimum pour
tous n'a jamais dit ça mais feront ttc
et beaucoup plus si son métal justice
on bannit les étudiants manifestent ils
ont peur de voir leur révolution
confisquée par le nouveau pouvoir
l'immigration revient à la une avec un
colloque socialiste sur ce thème à paris
et une déclaration de monsieur michel
rocard la france ne peut plus être une
terre d'immigration nouvelle après 4 107
jours d'occupation accord signé aux
chantiers navals de la ciotat entre la
cgt et la société américaine lexmark
définitivement préparer à bernard tapie
le français en phase de devenir une
langue morte dans le domaine
scientifique et technique qu'il faut
bien avouer que tout n'a pas été fait
pour préserver notre place dans ce
domaine une encyclopédie française
mondialement reconnue attend d'être
réédité depuis 15 ans maintenant
enquête dans cette édition madame
monsieur bonsoir l'actualité de ce
dimanche soir et celle des premiers
lendemain de révolution dans les pays de
l'est les populations qui peuvent enfin
s'exprimer n'entendent pas une nouvelle
fois se laisser confisquer la parole par
un groupe ou un parti politique unique
ainsi aujourd'hui à bucarest plusieurs
milliers d'étudiants roumain qui estime
que le nouveau pouvoir est un peu trop
proche de moscou est qu'il l'ait fruste
un peu trop rapidement d'une révolte
dont il croyait trop si les acteurs de
premier plan
reporter martine laroche-joubert gilbert
usant
mishara ville du premier massacre qui
l'avait d'une révolution dont chaque
jeune ici parce que les siennes ces
conditions qui pourraient peut-être
selon l'ars échappée qui ne demeurent
pas vigilants ce matin à l'institut
polytechnique de bucarest
ils étaient plusieurs milliers à vouloir
affirmer leur force leur unité face au
nouveau pouvoir à véritable réquisitoire
trop de bureaucratie représentation
étudiante vas-y inexistante autres du
gouvernement ne volonté d'être reconnu
maintenant la révolution quand il enlève
lui notamment sur l'excellent autre
révolution et alors on pourrait pas dire
que nous avons été confisqué et c'est
nous la révolution
on craint qu'elle ne soit confisquée c
est pour ça qu on essaie de nous
regrouper de protester et si c'est le
cas mais on a une chance maintenant et
on veut qu'on soit une france qui joue
roland pas des consignes
au bout de cet internement non non non à
prendre aux qui signifie la liberté mais
nous ne voulons pas je te tromper
réparer une chanson qui l'a ressemble à
pour nous
ce que nous avons connu relais des
coteaux verts et ps
les étudiants roumains n'étaient pas les
seuls à manifester aujourd'hui à
bucarest dans les rues de la capitale
quelques centaine de roumains
appartenant au parti paysan qui avant
l'arrivée des communistes au pouvoir il
ya 40 ans constituait le principal parti
politique du pays
des filets eux aussi sur les banderoles
on pouvait lire élections libres non
martyrs ont voulu la liberté le pain la
manifestation s'est terminée par un
dépôt de gerbe sur les lieux où sont
tombés les victimes des combats d'il ya
trois semaines maintenant dans la
capitale roumaine sur place en roumanie
encore nos envoyés spéciaux ont
l'occasion maintenant de revenir sur les
sommes qui ont été à l'origine de ce
soulèvement cela remonte à un mois tout
juste déjà premier week-end de décembre
manifestation souvenez vous dans les
rues de timisoara la frontière hongroise
sauvagement réprimée comme on le sait
les femmes et les hommes qui étaient
descendus dans la rue à l'époque
défendent est un pasteur menacés
d'expulsion pour son attitude envers le
régime de ceausescu son nom laszlo tokes
celui par qui tout a commencé reporter
nicolas jacobs claude sicard le bout du
monde 6 km de chemins de neige et de
boutons arrive est miné où quelques
centaines d'habitants au fin fond de la
transylvanie
c'est dans cette petite maison que vit
le symbole de la révolution la
securitate lee avait traîné de force
il y est encore étroitement surveillé
par l'armée à sa demande dit il se sent
encore menacé et puis le besoin de se
remettre de tant d'années de résistance
à timisoara années de peur année
d'extrême solitude des shops pour mon
évêque collaborer avec la securitate et
et le gouvernement est autre chose tous
voulaient m'exiler et m'ont fait subir
toutes sortes de persécution sécu
ministre hâtive disciplinaire décès d'un
des membres de mon presbytère a même été
tués les autres comme moi ont été
persécutés mais j'ai décidé de continuer
ma carrière ecclésiastique
mais bien sûr
il ya maintenant un défi à relever je
suis devenu le représentant non
seulement de la minorité hongroise dans
le pays ou de l'église protestante mais
aussi de tous les roumains et romaine et
de partout vient le voir des
représentants de cette minorité
hongroise de transylvanie une communauté
de deux millions de personnes parmi 20
millions de roubles jamais vraiment
intégré ils ont subi de ceausescu toutes
les humiliations toutes les persécutions
de kesh estime que la leçon de voir fait
reconnaître les droits de ses
compatriotes mais dans les épaules mais
je pense que le problème des minorités
c'est très important ce problème le
nouveau gouvernement roumain devra
aborder en priorité boat des sports
préférés
quelle sorte de mythe vous pour avoir
osé résister à l'asie caritate des faits
c'est une question difficile pour moi je
pense seulement qu'il y a une certaine
harmonie entre mes paroles et mes actes
et même à ceux là je les a pris de la
bible est également de mes parents
c'est quelque chose de naturel pour moi
et été formé
au même moment arrivait dans ce village
perdu un camion de médicaments et de
vêtements un chargement expressément
confié au pasteur l'homme en qui tout le
monde a confiance
l'homme qui a refusé d'entrer au
gouvernement l'homme de fer avec qui le
nouveau pouvoir devra forcément compter
les bouleversements à l'est ont non
seulement libéré les besoins de liberté
et de démocratie mais vous venez de le
voir ils ont aussi réveillé les
nationalismes les particularismes ainsi
le nouveau gouvernement de bulgarie qui
voulait accorder des droits à la
minorité turque du pays est obligé de
revenir quelque peu en arrière face au
mécontentement populaire qui s'est
manifestée d'ailleurs aujourd'hui dans
les rues de sofia comme vous le voyez
sur ces images plus de dix mille
personnes sont descendues dans les rues
de la capitale bulgare
ils ont même à un moment sifflé le
nouveau premier ministre qui voulait
s'adresser à eux comme vous voyez sur
ces images qui nous parviennent
d'ailleurs à l'instant il n'empêche que
des discussions entre la bulgarie et la
turquie doivent s'engager dans les
semaines qui viennent en politique
étrangère encore une déclaration à
l'emporte-pièce comme cet enfer le
colonel libyen kadhafi qui recevait
aujourd'hui le leader palestinien arafat
de nouveaux amis avec lui d'ailleurs
pour le colonel kadhafi israël doit
purement et simplement disparaître comme
le mur de berlin c'est l'image qu'il a
employés et selon lui toujours le
nouveau foyer pour l'émigration juive
pourrait être l'alaska l'alsace lorraine
ou les pays bas le président de l'ol
était monsieur arafat n'a pas donné son
avis sur cette déclaration
en france les problèmes liés à
l'intégration des immigrés dominer
l'actualité du mois de novembre avant
que ne se déclenchent vous savez les
formidable bouleversement à l'est le
sujet revient donc aujourd'hui sur le
devant de la scène avec un colloque
originale organisée à paris ce week-end
par des socialistes d'origine maghrébine
beurre ou pieds noirs qui avait demandé
à neuf ministres et au premier d'entre
eux monsieur roch à devenir plancher sur
ce thème
l'occasion pour le premier ministre
justement de réaffirmer clairement la
nouvelle position de la france reporters
olivier dernière question l'eau
ils n'étaient qu'une petite centaine à
applaudir michel rocard lorsqu au
troisième sous-sol de l'assemblée
nationale le premier ministre s'est
présenté devant eux
eux ce sont des élus socialistes pieds
noirs ou français maghrébins intéressés
au premier chef par les problèmes
d'immigration
aujourd'hui je le dis clairement pas de
plaisir à le dire j'ai beaucoup réfléchi
avant de d'assumer cette formule va
sembler que mon devoir était de l'assumé
complètement
la france n'est plus ne peut plus être
une terre d'immigration nouvelle je l'
ai déjà dit et je le réaffirme quelques
généreux qu'on soit nous ne pouvons
accueillir toute la misère du monde
un ange passe et le visage de georges
morin qui mène les débats depuis trois
jours ce christ
pas moins de huit ministres sont venus
donner leur sentiment à la tribune mais
aucun pas même michel rocard a évoqué un
hypothétique droits de vote qui pourrait
être accordée aux immigrés je pense que
les français sont de l'accès de l'est
présentement mais nous les socialistes
nous allons nous mettre en oeuvre pour
leur expliquer que sa nécessaire depuis
quelques années les conseils municipaux
se sont enrichis de quelques élus
originaires du maghreb
ils sont 300 représentants le ps et se
veulent des élus lambda je crois qu'on
juge selon mes compétences
vous êtes capable de faire et
en fonction d'autres choses notre
revendication essentielle c'est d'être
des français de plein exercice des
procès à part entière moi je ne l'exclus
pas la possibilité effectivement
pourquoi pas de voir un jour un ministre
d'origine maghrébine et je suis sûr
qu'il fera un bon ministre
qu'est-ce donc que l'intégration plutôt
connaît-elle pas cette question posée
aujourd'hui par michel rocard l'ancien
maire de dreux françoise gaspard l'a
travaillé pendant des mois aujourd'hui
elle se tient en retrait mais elle n'en
pense pas moins
françoise gaspard qui a été maire de
dreux et la politique un peu plus
politiciennes dont il apparaît
maintenant exclu que le courant dit
mitterrandiste au sein du parti
socialiste se présente unie au prochain
congrès du parti socialiste à rennes au
mois de mars prochain
le président de l'assemblée nationale en
effet monsieur laurent fabius a décidé
avec ses amis politiques de maintenir sa
propre constitution
refusant d'effectuer une synthèse avec
d'autres courants jean-michel mercurol
de synthèse dimanche prochain pour
laurent fabius il ne veut pas signer un
texte de replâtrage avec jospin peu près
nous mermaz pour la première fois les
mitterrandie s'avance donc divisé pour
le congrès faire la synthèse maintenant
10 fabius aboutirait à priver de parole
les militants les fabiusiens vont donc
se compter ils espèrent peser d'un poids
égal avec justin au roi d'une part et
les rocardiens d'autre part
personnellement je souhaite une vraie
synthèse et c'est sur ce qui s'appelle
une vraie synthèse que je voudrais dire
quelques mots
assurément ce n'est pas un replâtrage a
quelques-uns qui serait d'ailleurs mal
accueilli je crois dans les profondeurs
du parti et plus encore dans le pays
mais cette un accord de fond et puisse
s'appuyer sur le vote des militants est
un réponse ne s'est pas fait attendre
lionel jospin lui voudrait continuer à
tendre la main à laurent fabius
laurent fabius lundi de même que je suis
prêt à la faire avec milner man avec
jean poperen
voir ensuite comment nous pouvons nous
entendre avec michel rocard ou jean
pierre chevènement
donc je suis prêt à faire ça tout de
suite je pense effectivement que
l'attitude de laurent fabius qui
souhaite absolument semble-t-il se
compter avec ses partisans et celle qui
risque d'empêcher la synthèse alors
diviseur laurent fabius nullement selon
lui puisqu'il promet de refaire l'union
avec les autres mitterrandiste juste
avant le congrès et qu'il invite j'ose
pas poperen et mermaz à s'engager à
faire comme lui faut bien s'accrocher
pour suivre
au terme de quatre cents sept jours
d'occupation là c'est plus simple la cgt
des chiens on veut d'ailleurs la cgt des
chantiers de la ciotat a accepté de
signer un accord avec la société
américaine lexmark qui s'engage à
remettre en marche le chantier naval en
créant d'abord une centaine d'emplois
seulement cet accord met un terme à
plusieurs mois de valse hésitation la
cgt et le conseil général des bouches du
rhône préférant finalement donc la
solution américaine au projet de bernard
tapie qui était souvenez-vous soutenu
par le gouvernement reporter patrice
blais pascal puillon accord en fanfare
sous les grues du chantier un an et demi
d'occupation pour obtenir enfin un début
de relance du site de la ciotat avec en
symbole une avance sur salaire de 5000
francs pour chacun une distribution dans
la liesse
sous l'oeil des familles des grévistes
oui on a gagné will be / g / quarantaine
de chacun et sont fait plaisir aussi
et lundi on reprend le travail avec la
la joie voyez ça fait plaisir
les 105 embauché travailleront dès
demain au nettoyage à la remise en état
des chantiers un accord qui récompensent
l'obstination de la cgt a refusé la fin
de la navale à la ciotat
c'est une très bonne accord parce que
ils posent à la hauteur des salaires
entre autres et de la formation
professionnelle des choses pratiquement
unique dans le département des bouches
du rhône sont faits pour les salariés un
bon accord l'année s'affichent et des
salaires entre 6500 et quatorze mille
francs laveix marc a voulu prouver sa
bonne volonté
elle devra faire encore plus convaincre
et obtenir le droit d'utiliser
l'outillage pour le moment en possession
de la banque worms l'accord signé ce
matin est nécessaire mais pas suffisant
pour construire des bateaux les
adversaires de la lexmark le savent bien
le gouvernement comme la mairie de la
ciotat n'attendent qu'une chose le
premier faux-pas du groupe américano
suédois
le président de la république monsieur
françois mitterrand a exercé son droit
de grâce
yves ponthieu 43 ans a donc été libéré
de la prison de loos les lille où il
purgeait une peine de 20 ans pour le
viol et le meurtre d'une infirmière
c'était en 1980 dans un premier temps
yves ponthieu avait avoué pour se
rétracter tout de suite après et depuis
clamé son innocence
le procès fera d'ailleurs apparaître un
manque évident de preuves matérielles
pour autant il bon dieu sera tout de
même condamné il sera resté neuf ans en
prison il va demander dès demain la
révision de son procès a nié ce point
les toutes premières heures de liberté
après neuf ans de prison neuf ans a
clamé son innocence il ponctué libre
gracié par le président de la république
mais pour lui rien n'est réglé mais
attention celle de continuer le combat
pour obtenir première manche
la révision de son procès et puis
l'acquittement
vous priez toujours votre innocence
j'ai créé mon innocence juillet 81 les
gendarmes découvrent sur la route de
bourg-en-bresse le corps calciné de
monique soubeyrand infirmière à
l'hôpital et hauteville lompnès elle a
été violée puis étranglée auprès du
corps les gendarmes retrouvent de livres
érotiques
le libraire de longuenesse affirmé avoir
vendu un collègue de la jeune infirmière
économe à l'hôpital yves ponthieu placé
en garde à vue il ponctue eux avouent
puis se rétracte aussitôt en 1983 il est
condamné à 20 ans de réclusion
criminelle
un comité de soutien se forment et
refait l'enquète en vérifiant d'abord
les facture du fournisseur du libraire
la dral diffusion rhône-alpes du libre
les deux livres érotiques sur lesquelles
est basé l'accusation n'ont jamais été
livrés aux libraires pour le comité de
soutien et pour les avocats disent
ponthieu aucun doute
l'enquète a été trop rapide et les aveux
arrachés
bon je crois qu'il ya un mécanisme
psychologique qui fait qu' un homme
comice ponthieu avec une femme qui était
enceinte au moment
moment de son interpellation avec la
tante de l'enfant qu'ils allaient avoir
ensemble la certitude peut être d'être
libéré certaine violence m'at-il dit de
la part de la part des gendarmes une
pression psychologique intense fond je
pense que des aveux ont été ont été
quelque peu arraché aventure ou du moins
il a cru si la crue se libérer de ce
calvaire en avouant quelque chose qui
n'avait pas fait ils font tuer à
retrouver son foyer ses quatre enfants
aujourd'hui gracié il veut maintenant
être réhabilité cette affaire est
maintenant dans un tout autre genre
vrai ou faux en tout cas une de ces
histoires incroyables de soldats qui
depuis quarante deux ans maintenant ne
s'était pas aperçu que le clairon de
l'armistice avait sonné d'habitude et
bien vous savez ce sont les japonais que
l'on retrouve perdu dans les îles du
pacifique cette fois ci c'est un soldat
de l'armée rouge qui était resté tapi
dans les bois valérie fourni il revient
du nid ans dont c'est ce que dit le
commentateur de la télévision soviétique
cet homme ivan vassilevitch bouscau
serait resté 42 ans dans une forêt se
cachant des hommes avec pour seule
préoccupation de ne pas laisser de
traces parce que tout simplement ils
avaient peur de la cruauté de ses
semblables
ivan 67 ans un simple paysan un ancien
soldat choqué par la violence des hommes
dont voici le logement sans arme à feu
il piégeait les animaux de la forêt pour
se nourrir jamais assure-t-il
pendant 42 ans il ne verra un homme mais
remarque le journaliste soviétique
il est pourtant extraordinairement
courant de ce qui se passe en urss dans
notre pays pourquoi n'avez-vous pas
quitter votre cachette plus tôt je me
suis pas sorti parce que je n'avais
confiance en personne
aujourd'hui seulement je fais confiance
en gorbatchev et seulement gorbatchev
une prise de conscience comme une
révélation me confiance totale en la
personne du numéro un soviétique très
étonnante
mais après tout l'histoire est belle et
que peut dire d'autre un homme qui
aurait quitté le monde sous staline pour
ressurgit
l'heure de la glace nous revenons à des
préoccupations plus terre à terre
concernant directement notre
environnement en parcourant la campagne
vous êtes sans doute aperçu que
l'agriculture française emploie de plus
en plus de matières plastiques pour
abriter les serres par exemple ou encore
pour protéger au sol les plantations
comment ces produits sont ils recyclent
et car ils le sont en quête de josé
blanc la pierre et jean louis normande
cette scène vous ne la verrez pas tous
les jours ces deux agriculteurs font
partie d'une minorité leurs déchets il
ne les brûlent pas il ne les jette pas
il les déversent dans cette benne après
un tri direction l'incinérateur dans le
département 75 tonnes de plastique ont
ainsi été récupérés cette année des
agriculteurs confirmant ce que l'on dit
ce ne sont pas des pollueurs il respecte
l'environnement alors on essaye de faire
le maximum est fait comprendre aux
citadins aussi que nous on est dans la
foulée pour protéger la nature
l'agriculture c'est 10% du plastique
consommée en france 50 mille tonnes
répandu dans la nature des bâches sous
lesquels fermente la nourriture du
bétail le toit qui piège les rayons du
soleil des kilomètres de plastique qu'il
faut jeter régulièrement sans polluer en
l'absence de réglementation des
initiatives voient le jour
en 90 eh bien nous allons passer dans
une phase d'organisation de la
récupération des plastiques et bien
entendu au delà de cette récupération à
savoir l'incinération et
3 certainement le recyclage est une voie
intéressante le recyclage se pratique
déjà dans cette usine
le plastique usagées est d'abord
nettoyer sécher réduit en granulés il
rejoint la chaîne de fabrication à la
sortie il est transformé en sacs
poubelles ici le recyclage pourrait être
multiplié par dix l'obstacle le pré du
plastique usagées plus élevé que la
matière première vierge
la collecte elle-même coûte cher la
pollution à des solutions mais qui
paiera la facture
éclectique notre journal nous passons
maintenant à la science cette semaine
aura lieu à paris un forum sur le thème
comment préserver l'emploi du français
dans le domaine scientifique et
technique un combat presque désespérée
selon les paroles même du ministre de la
francophonie monsieur alain de cons il
faut dire que dans le passé nous n'avons
peut-être pas fait tout ce qu'il fallait
pour maintenir notre langue au niveau
international dans ces domaines exemple
une encyclopédie mondiale des sciences
et techniques reconnues par les plus
grands noms ne trouve pas d'éditeur
depuis 15 ans maintenant reporter
jacques violet dominique merlet sur le
bureau de roger morvan encyclopédistes
les dix volumes de l'encyclopédie
internationale des sciences et des
techniques
3600 article 9000 pages 2500 renvoi et
800 schéma dix ans de travail et la
collaboration de 800 savant français
dont plusieurs nobel je me suis rangé
dans une encyclopédie au départ
certainement pour disposer d'un ouvrage
que je ne trouvais pas et qui n'existait
pas alors ce qui fait courir une
encyclopédie ce tu sais je crois
sincèrement le désir jusqu'à sa mort de
servir la communauté dans laquelle il
vit mais là ça peut paraître un peu
excentrique mais c'est ça il a réussi à
faire une oeuvre communautaire faire
faire une oeuvre communautaire de
manière extraordinaire mais sans sa
ténacité sa patience et le fait que la
communauté très vite lui accorder une
totale confiance
rien ne se serait passé en 1978 après un
premier tirage de 20 mille exemplaires
l'éditeur dit
de ne pas poursuivre depuis 1981
l'ouvragé donc épuisé projet morvan ne
trouve pas d'éditeur mais il continue il
actualise son encyclopédie
il court les labos des coupes écoles les
articles cette somme de connaissances
énorme est en sommeil le savoir à
l'abandon suite le penny internationale
des sciences et des techniques telles
que les fait partie maintenant du
patrimoine de la france et c'est un
patrimoine qui ne faut pas laisser
complètement mourir complètement d'un
patrimoine qu'il faut sauver la mort
vent comme on l'appelle n'est donc pas
dépasser il suffit de l'avis de tous de
rééditer les dix volumes épuisé en y
ajoutant un volume d'actualisation le
français a tout à y gagner
pour cesser de nous plaindre de la
suprématie de l'anglais dans les
disciplines scientifiques
un autre élément de notre patrimoine en
danger un des monuments les plus connus
du monde que vous voyez derrière moi la
tour de pise en italie huit cent mille
visiteurs par an a fermé aujourd'hui ses
portes aux touristes pour des raisons de
sécurité la tour est en très mauvais
état des morceaux de marbre tombent
régulièrement par terre et des
réparations sont donc nécessaires mais
rien n'indique en revanche qu'elle
tombera du côté où elle penche véronique
gallienne comme un dernier hommage à la
belle de toscane plus d'un millier de
soupirants escaladé ce matin les 293
marches de la tour de marbre ici le
dernier visiteur la télévision italienne
retransmettaient en directe la fermeture
des lourdes portes fermées juste le
temps d'un lifting trois mois pour les
plus optimistes sûrement davantage selon
les experts car il faudra du temps pour
restaurer colonisé arcade et surtout
consolider les fragiles fondations
après huit siècles d'histoire latour
penche aujourd'hui de quatre mètres 40
par rapport à la verticale
cette inclinaison s'est ralenti ces
dernières années et l'édifice aurait pu
tenir encore 100 ans avant de
s'effondrer mais à présent sa façade se
fissure et s'effritent et la place des
miracles devient d'un abord dangereux un
anneau de béton armé devrait pouvoir
arrimer au sol la vieille tour et la
maintenir d'aplomb mais toujours penché
rugby et au val lui publication ce soir
deux des membres de l'équipe de france
qui jouera le premier match du tournoi
des cinq nations contre le pays de
galles à cardiff le 20 janvier prochain
vous allez voir s'inscrire sur votre
écran la liste de cette équipe
la voici retour des valeurs sûres comme
blanco rodriguez berbizier qui avait
disparu la dernière fois et réapparition
du toulousain charvet qui lui avait
quitté l'équipe de france depuis
quelques temps déjà dans l'ensemble
plutôt une équipe classique avec donc
très très peu de nouveaux éléments sport
encore avec une victoire française en
ski acrobatique au canada edgar
grospiron premier il est français
six français dans les dix premiers au
moins donc une chance de médaille pour
les prochains olympiques jeux olympiques
d'hiver à albertville en 1992 où le ski
acrobatique où le signal sera son entrée
dans la compétition officielle c'est
très beau à voir
olivier rey ça plane pour l'équipe de
france de ski acrobatique à mont gabriel
on canada les français ont largement
dominé l'épreuve des bosses autant pour
la coupe du monde
en classant 6e leurs représentants dans
les dix premiers c'est le dernier
vainqueur de la coupe du monde le
français edgar grospiron ici en action
qui a enlevé la première place devançant
son compatriote olivier allaman la
troisième place revenant au suisse
bernard edgar grospiron bien en jambes a
fait admirer une fois encore tout son
talent à deux ans des jeux d'albertville
coup les boss seront pendards première
fois discipline olympique
la france peut se montrer optimiste tant
elle survole aujourd'hui cette
spécialité
chez les dames la victoire est revenue à
l'américaine gwen brèche devant la
canadienne lee morrison et la française
raphaël mono voilà est une discipline
qui n'est pas olympique mais qui est
très prisé le tiercé pour gagner
aujourd'hui il fallait jouer le 6 le 13
le 17 ça rapporte 710 francs pour 5
francs et pour ce qui concerne le quarté
+ s'ajouter le 9 à ces premiers chiffres
et vous gagnez 2142 franc visiblement
tous les favoris et est à l'arrêt
voilà ce journal est terminée tout de
suite après les prévisions météo de ce
début
semaine avec josé dans la pierre après
le policier dernière édition du journal
aux alentours de 23 heures 57 avec
philippe gassot demain vous retrouvez
toute l'équipe de la rédaction d'antenne
2 avec hervé clos d'ici demain soir à
20h quant à moi je vous retrouver avec
toute l'équipe du week-end samedi
prochain dès 13h bonne semaine soir
oh